hi guys compares here I am asked a lot
about evening routines so I'm going to
show you what my current routine looks
like pretty bad so let's say that I'm
about sixty minutes out I want to go to
bed 60 minutes I'm going to make myself
some tea that is decaffeinated these
days it is Douglas fir spring tip by
Juniper Ridge the stuff right here it is
fantastic I first bought it at the San
Francisco Ferry Building farmers market
which is on Thursdays and Saturdays this
stuff has become a real favorite now
into that tea once I've steeped it and
taken out the bag I will put in apple
cider vinegar one or two tablespoons and
then I'll also put this is assuming I'm
having trouble sleeping and need to get
to sleep and a tablespoon of unfiltered
honey alright this is a tip borrowed
from my late friend Seth Roberts an
amazing guy and I am not 100% sure on
the biochemistry behind why this works
but it knocks you out like that many of
my friends who are chronic insomniacs
have credited this with better sleep
than even prescription medication so I'm
not doctor don't play one on the
internet so stay on your meds talk to
your doctors bla bla bla but this
combination of apple cider vinegar plus
the honey which I would just add to this
tea is literally a knockout it's
incredible
now at that point I will turn on my
downstairs soaking tub and we're going
to get some footage of that in a second
that takes about 15 minutes to fill and
I'll sit down and I'll read fiction
alright I'm not going to read something
like a nonfiction business book that's
going to keep my problem-solving
apparatus in sixth gear that's not
helpful I need to turn that off so I'll
read fiction this is a book that I just
finished which was recommended to me by
a billionaire investor named Chris Sacca
who's also a friend and has been on the
podcast telling the tim ferriss show and
it is called how to get filthy rich in
rising Asia by I'm guessing pronounced
Mohsin Hamid this is a fantastic book I
mean it is just incredible
prose so pure and purposeful it passes
straight through into the bloodstream it
intoxicates the New York Times Book
Review a globalized version of The Great
Gatsby
his book is nearly that good NPR it's
fantastic and very hilarious so I just
finished this fiction then at that point
I'll set an alarm let's say it's 13
minutes in I will fill up this thermos
effectively with water and a ton of ice
now this Hydra flask 40 ounce Hydra
flask is also something I travel with
why this is actually kind of cool
because it doubles as a foam roller but
it's not foam so I will use this to
actually roll out my hip flexors and
whatnot when I'm on the road and it
saves me the trouble of packing both so
I can just clip this onto my carry-on
with the carabiner and off I go now I
have this which is going to be a core
literally core component of thermal
regulation and then I had downstairs
that's were gone next so here we are
downstairs
got the Houdini of all sorts of other
artwork this room used to be just like a
dirty futon room with a PlayStation the
previous owners didn't know to do with
it so I stripped out everything and I
built something that I've wanted since I
was fifteen and lived in Japan and had a
nightly akuto so this is what it looks
like and try not to completely kill
lighting here but if you come in you can
see that this has been made into my spa
room effectively complete with the
shelves with towels and everything so
this is a soaking tub and each night I
will get in here I have my ice water
this will sit at this point right here I
have a thermometer if I really want to
check water temperature books I'll
sometimes alternate this with ice baths
in the other room and then you have
steps that give you different depths so
I can go from about here to here to here
all right now there are no jets this is
not a Jacuzzi this is a soaking tub
and to that end I have a bunch of stuff
in here
these are different types of epsom salts
and medicinal salts that are in dog food
rolling containers so this is Epsom salt
magnesium sulfate that I buy bulk and I
will just take two gigantic glasses
worth or jars worth of this and put it
into the tub I also have a number of
different oils and so on that depending
on my training I can use and if we come
around the corner here you can see that
we have cozy little sauna so this is a
dry sauna for two people it's a tight
fit you could get someone on the floor
also if they're a little overheated and
I will play with this for not only just
regular banya shits and purposes but
also for increasing endurance and if
you're interested in that you can look
up Rhonda Patrick Rho and DA Rhonda
Patrick PhD and sauna and Ferriss if
there's an entire 10 page post on how to
use heat exposure for growth hormone
increases and improved endurance and
that is in effect my evening routine so
starts upstairs and down here I will
consume the ice water every two or three
cycles into that bath I'll usually
listen to an audio book of some type or
presentations that are motivational in
some capacity and then shower and off to
bed and having already had the cocktail
with the apple cider vinegar and the
honey I'm out like a light I am a
lifelong insomniac and I no longer have
some pain in part due to having a
consistent nightly ritual did you like
this if you like this you're going to
love what's waiting right here click
Subscribe I have some amazing stuff
coming